now before we start the algorithms one
more time a disclaimer these results are
coming from scientific papers and if you
come up with a new method you want to
show that this method outperforms
existing methods in the scenes or in the
setups that you have tried and some
people are very open about the
limitations of the techniques because if
I have a technique that's better than
the best technique out there on this
scene that's great but it doesn't mean
that it will be better on all possible
scenes and some people are very candid
about the limitations of the algorithms
and some of them are not so candid about
this but with time as people start to
use the algorithm these possible corner
cases or just simply difficult cases
come up so what do I mean by this what I
mean is that if you see great results
that there's an algorithm wonderful
results it's the best thing ever okay
but always have a slight doubt whether
this algorithm would be robust enough
would it always work when we did not
work because don't just extrapolate from
one case there may be drawbacks that are
maybe not so clean not so clear where
you first see the algorithm now
mathematical details again will be
omitted mostly and but what we are
interested in the motivation for each
algorithm what is the key idea what are
the advantages disadvantages how do the
results look like where can you access
implementations where can you try these
and for most of them some additional
literature if you think that wow this is
a really great algorithm I would like to
know more than there will be links you
click them and then you can read either
the paper or some writings about them so
let's get started part racing from 1986
super old stuff but this is the very
first and the easiest way to wrap your
head around global illumination
you start
you're raised from the eye or the camera
you bounce them around the scene if you
would like to earn some style points
then after every bounce you would also
trace shadow rays towards the light
source this is next event estimation
this usually lowers your variance and
then you end up somewhere you compute
all these light paths and totally good
you don't do any simplifications to the
integral you exhaustively sample all
possible light paths
there's no interpolation no tricks no
magic so this should be an unbiased and
consistent algorithm and bias the error
is predictable I know that if I add more
samples there's gonna be less error and
I know that sooner or later the image is
going to converge because I am sampling
all possible light paths there are it is
impossible that I would miss something
now there may be corner cases but they
are really difficult but fortunately
well-understood corner cases where there
are contributions that you may miss I
will discuss this during the next
lecture what are the advantages it's
simple it's also very easy to implement
I didn't write it there but it also
paralyzes well why because it's a dump
algorithm it doesn't do anything tricky
it doesn't build super difficult and
super complicated data structures you
just put it on the GPU and you just ran
out as many and you just dish out as
many light paths per second as possible
what is a common problem that people
encounter with this but for instance
caustics converge very slowly because
caustics are usually light paths that
are extremely improbable to be sampled
and you would need to compute many many
samples in order to hit these caustics
many times in order to clean them up
clear them up onwards 1993
bi-directional path tracing what is the
motivation behind this guy well imagine
a scene that this is your camera on the
left and you have a light source for
instance enclosed in this object which
is for now for the sake of experiment
black body so if you hit it from
anywhere it's not a glass lightbulb or
anything like that it's a black body so
whichever part of the container you hit
you won't continue your attack now you
would start a podracer what do you do
you start tracing the rays from the
camera and it is not too likely to hit
the light source is it so it's not a
point light source it's an area light
source it is possible to hit it but it's
not very likely now after the previous
lecture you would say no problem
next event estimation what do I do I
don't wait until I hit the light source
I would send out shadow rays after every
bounce and I would get some of the
energy of the light source the direct
contribution of the light source great
but the problem is that this also
doesn't work because most of the
connections would be obstructed because
if I hit this very first bounce I cannot
keep the light source because there's
the black body that contains it after
the second bounce I also cannot connect
to the light source it's again even with
next event estimation most of my samples
are wasted we are tracing random rays it
is very unlikely to hit the light source
and even if I connect to the light
source it is very unlikely that I will
see an obstructed connection what is the
solution
bi-directional path tracing what happens
here is that I am not starting only one
light path from the eye I start to light
paths one from the eye as with regular
path tracing and I also start light
paths starting out from the light
sources this is called light tracing and
I try to combine these two techniques
into one framework so what it means is
that I start one or a given number of
bounces from the eye I start a given
number of bounces from the light source
and then I connect these light paths
together and I pretend that I just built
this light path instead and now it is I
have a much better chance to sample
these light sources because I
would have the opportunity to get out of
that small zone that is otherwise
difficult to hit from the eye now let's
see the difference between the two
techniques these are taken after
10-second for the very same scene and
you could say that there's a huge
difference for this indoor scene between
the two so it's definitely worth looking
into now what is actually difficult
about bidirectional path tracing is that
theoretically it's very simple there is
not one light path there are two and I
connect them in all possible different
ways now what you should take into
consideration is that this is actually
two monte carlo processes one monte
carlo process is when you start out from
the eye and you hit a diffuser a glossy
object then you would start to important
sample it important sample the brdf this
means that I would take the likely paths
more often now if you start a light path
from the light source then what you will
be sampling is actually the distribution
of the light source itself because
regions that are visible from the light
source would be sampled extensively with
light tracing because you're always
hitting them they are in front of you
and that's a completely different
sampling distribution so you can imagine
as if you had two different monte carlo
processes that sample the very same
integrand and one monte carlo process
would have some variance and the other
would have some other variance so
different regions of the of the path
space different and also different
regions of the image would converge
quicker with light racing and different
images would would converge quicker with
standard path tracing and I would like
to combine these two techniques together
and this is entirely not reveal variance
I've written not noise in there to be
more intuitive but we're talking about
variance that noise comes from
variance variance is an additive
quantity so this means that if I have
two monte carlo estimators of given
variance and if I would just add them
together and average these samples then
I would also average the error of the
two and that that doesn't give me that
that doesn't give me a great result
because there are some regions that are
sampled by light racing well and there
are regions that are sampled by part
racing well and I cannot just cut out
the good parts from each sampling
technique because the error would be
averaged and this can be solved in a
meaningful way in a way that is actually
proven to be optimal in some sense and
this technique is called multiple
important sampling now multiple
importance sampling was brought to us by
a person called Eric rich in his
landmark thesis of beautiful beautiful
works bidirectional podracing is one of
them and he if I remember correctly last
year he got an Academy Award for his
work this is basically gone this is
basically the on technical Oscar award
if you will and in his acceptance speech
it was really funny because he has a
daughter and his daughter had taken a
look at his thesis which is hundreds of
pages of heavy integral calculus and and
she asked that that daddy do people
actually read this huge tome of
knowledge and he finally can say that
yes people actually do read that we read
it like the Holy Bible
multiple important sampling is among one
of his discoveries and it is maybe but I
mean it's a bit subjective maybe the
most powerful technique in there in all
rendering and I will show you plenty of
examples to convince you that this is so
so on the Left let's let's forget about
the middle example for now let's just
compare the left and the right you can
see that there are many artifact
and many of these fireflies that can be
suppressed by this technique so I can
unify multiple sampling techniques in a
way that wherever they do really bad I
can just forget that and I would take
only the best samples for each region
let's take another look which is maybe
even better this is called at least this
is what we call of each pyramid this is
created with bi-directional path tracing
and the code below each image means that
we have taken a different number of
steps from the light source and from the
eye so in every image you see one given
number of bounces so if you would have
path tracing you would get like ten or
something images not in a pyramid one
image would be the first bounce second
image would be the second bounce third
image would be the third pass for
bi-directional path tracing you have a
pyramid like that because you subdivide
them to the first bounce from the eye
and the some bounce from the light
source so this is now the
two-dimensional thing and you can see
that some of the effects are captured
really well in some of these images and
there are some other images which are
absolutely absolutely terrible and
really noisy so for instance if you take
a look at the two sides these two sides
mean that I am hitting either the camera
or the light source by accident and if
you have a small light source which we
actually do look here then this is a
relatively low probability event and if
there and if this is a low probability
event and most of my samples are going
to be wasted and I'm going to be have a
noisy image not too well converged image
so on the sides I have really low
probability events and these are samples
that I really don't want to use imagine
that I would add all of these images
together average them I would have
plenty of noise from the noisy ones now
what if I could say that if you take a
look at
equals one T equals five you can see
that we have plastics in there and the
caustics is almost almost immediately
converged in there it is definitely good
in a sense that I would for caustics I
definitely would want to use these
samples and not the ones for instance in
s equals zero T equals six because
there's also caustics but it's really
noisy it is not systematically looking
for caustics it just happened to hit it
but it's not good at sampling it and I
don't want to average these guys
together what I want to what I would
want to do is I would want to give a
large weight to s it was one T was five
on caustics and I would just grab it in
there in my image and I would just
forget about the other contributions and
this is mathematically doing this in a
mathematically sound way is not easy but
eric has proven really good and super
simple technique on how to do that and
now look closely to the image this is
without naive bidirectional path
pressing without multiple important
sampling and now what you will see is if
we add multiple importance sampling so
look closely see the difference
there are many noisy images that were
completely shut down because they were
not really good at sampling different
parts of the space of light paths some
images are not good at anything at all
take a look at the two sides and there
are images where I can take caustics
from for instance like the s equals 5 T
equals 1 it seems to have been even
better at sampling caustics because this
nesic was one T equals five was also
pretty good but it was shut down by the
other technique that was even better so
this is an amazingly powerful technique
in order to create even even more
converged images if you have multiple
sampling strategies now you can also
play with it it is implemented on shader
TOI the nice classical vide scene where
there is light source sampling and VSD
the idea of sampling and it doesn't
matter if you sell vs the F or brdf in
this case by the way but you remember so
you can play with it and I encourage you
to do so it is lots of fun and you will
see what kind of light transport
situations are captured well with with
sampling technique and how to unify them
in a way that everything looks converged
almost immediately and also what does a
good engineer do well a good engineer
obviously is interested in the problem
so I just sat down and also implemented
the same thing in a simple example in
one deed to make sure that everyone
really understands what is going on so
this is a simple Monte Carlo sampling
problem in 1d I have a function that I
would want to integrate if I remember
correctly I am integrating a Gaussian
and I would like to sample it with two
different techniques so this is two
different Monte Carlo sampling processes
and I would want to take only the best
samples in order to get an approximation
which has the least variance and there
are multiple ways of combining them
together and there's also naive
averaging which just average is the
error so it would give you back all of
these images from the side and I write
out what are the exact Monte Carlo
estimators for different multiple
important sampling estimators as well so
take a look at is now part of small
paint and you can run it super simple
and hopefully super understandable I
think it is less than 100 lines of code
okay so what we now know by direction of
path tracing definitely better converge
converging speed especially in scenes
where you are not depth likely to hit
light sources so especially in indoor
scenes and you will also get quicker
convergence for caustics because you
will have sampling strategies that are
very efficient in that so plastics are
usually visible from light sources and
you will sample them very
often so there's gonna be at least one
estimator that captures it well so if
you use M is multiple important sampling
you're gonna have caustics covered very
quickly now it is definitely not easy to
grasp and it is definitely not easy to
implement so it requires quite a bit of
an effort even if it sounds very
intuitive it is but it is not easy this
is also a brute-force method
this also samples all possible light
sources and therefore this is also
unbiased and consistent some more
literature on bi-directional path
tracing and even better there is a nice
comparison coded up also on shader toi
so when you are at home just fire it up
and you will see the difference evolving
in real time on your GPU on an indoor
scene